hey guys big announcement my special
Lefty son will be dropping Wednesday
April 5th on my YouTube it's free go
watch it support it like it subscribe I
shot it here in LA in December at the
dynasty theater and I'm really proud of
it so go check it out April 5th
Wednesday Lefty sun on my YouTube
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media I want to thank you again
as always whether you're new here or
whether you've been here thank you for
supporting this show
um I really appreciate all the love if
you're watching get in there please
subscribe uh we have guests like this so
hit that subscribe button and if you
gotta have more you gotta check out the
patreons called the Honeydew with you
all where I do this exact thing with
y'all
and y'all got the wildest [__]
episodes I've ever heard in my life
double lung transplant people died it's
insane all right yeah it's insane dudes
five bucks a month you know the deal all
right now you uh catch me in Fort Wayne
Indiana May 26th and 27th June 23rd and
24th I'm in Tacoma Washington July 7th
and 8th Appleton Wisconsin July 21st and
22nd Tulsa Oklahoma and make sure you
watch my brand new special on YouTube it
drops Wednesday April 5th it's called
Lefty son watch it subscribe support it
thank you very much that's the biz all
right now you know what we do here we
highlight the low lights I always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers I'm very excited to have
this guest on here today ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome logic welcome
to the Honeydew lodging hey thanks a lot
thank you for your patience over there
with that intro I know I'm just so
excited I've been trying to do this
interview for like 30 minutes
but we but we just keep talking about
cool [__] which is like [__] up
everything no it's not I know it's not
but you know what I mean but what I
wanna first of all thank you for being
here I'm really excited appreciate your
time thank you uh you're a Maryland dude
so when I found that out I was extra
excited I always got an extra love for
Marilyn
um but before we get uh please plug I'm
really listening to you I just don't
know what to do with my hands right now
do whatever you be comfortable I know
but this is like I don't know you know
what I mean this is like look at this
this I do this a lot you do that that's
that's comfortable for me because I like
to lean in that's yeah but then I you
can't see the money shot of me that
because I'm hiding yeah you probably
you'd probably dipped out now I'm just
kidding I'm happy to meet you there
sorry what were you gonna say I wanna I
want you to plug and promote everything
you want to get out right now we'll do
it again at the end okay I am here to
promote peace love and positivity I'm
here to promote myself and uh positive
outlook and I'm also going on tour in
May so look that [__] up if you want and
if not who gives a [__] I'm just happy
to be here and talk about cool stuff
with you thank you thank you dude
um so we were talking before the podcast
and I asked you what made you want to
start doing podcasts because I I'm a fan
I've watched a lot of your stuff you
incorporate sketches you you lean into
comedy which I like yeah
um and you had an interesting answer so
what what why are you doing podcasts
right now well first and foremost I
think I lead into comedy because of all
the pain that I've gone through and
laughter
really
is great but so is crying because it's
good to get that out but I think we can
talk about super serious [__]
when we're laughing you know what I mean
and so that's why I like to do that and
the the reason that I'm making I'm not
even this these I'm not making rounds
this is what I'm doing okay I woke up
one day and realized that the brand of
logic and me as Bobby as just a [__]
guy
will always be bigger
than the music that I make I know that
it will and I know that it is and I know
the fact that when fans buy tickets to a
tour
that
they that they
they're not just coming to hear the song
some of them are
but most people are coming for the show
and it is like half stand up half rap
like it's kind of wild actually yeah but
I'm I'm being myself and I'm being
honest and what I realized is like I'm
going insane on social media now
and for a long time I didn't because
social media was a very hard place to
terrain the internet it is right it's
full of negativity it is insane it's a
bloodbath and I used to be so angry at
myself when I would uh find that I was
hurt by something so if something hurt
me if somebody's like oh you know I hope
your family dies in a car accident
would you would you find that you would
get like a thousand positive comments
and that one negative from the guy it's
got 14 [__] followers that's the one
to eat you alive yes and the re and and
then it was to a point where I wasn't
focusing I was focusing more on the
negative than the positive
um because I couldn't wrap my head
around because I'm empathetic so I was
like why would this person say this
right like why would they do I don't
understand it well I don't understand it
because I'm not a [__] that's really
what it is it's like you know what I'm
saying it's like ah yeah it is what it
is like I I understand what it's like to
be broke because I was once broke as
hell but I've never been a a bad person
I've done some bad things you know what
I mean as a kid you make stupid mistakes
whatever but I internally was never
I never let that happen but what what
that really is is just people going
through their own pain and their own
suffering and maybe not even realizing
it and um saying the things that they do
so for me but real quick it takes a
mature personal and your end to
understand and realize that instead of
just to spit fire back agreed I mean
it'd be fun to call him [__] boys yeah
all this other [__] but some of them
need it though some of them need but not
for me that's why the best part is it's
just like the internet also works both
ways that's right the fans will take
care of it they'll take care of it and
they'll take care of it in a pretty
positive way for the most part but I
realized
it's okay that these things hurt me
because I am a sensitive emotional human
being and the world let alone hip-hop
likes to make men feel like can't talk
about your feelings you have to keep
everything yeah bottle it all up and
then you can put a bullet in your head
no that's that's and when I realized
it's okay that someone's saying they
hope my entire family dies
it's okay that that hurts and so when I
allowed that because I used to go why
why you know and people literally on the
internet would be like you gotta have
tough skin bro and it's like nah fam
like no like and so once I realized that
it's okay that it hurts I then realized
that I was in control of how long I let
it hurt and how much I let it hurt me
very much so like an intrusive thought
so once realizing this I took control
back and now when somebody some [__] boy
says something about me or whatever the
case may be I'm like damn that hurts
because maybe I even like that person or
it could be another rapper or famous per
whatever and I'm like damn
but it is what it is my son's healthy my
wife is beautiful
I have like five houses
I am so blessed like am I really worried
about this and for a year a decade I was
worried about that it would bother you
that long yeah and now certain things
still bother me but I don't let them
bother me for a long time and I also am
not on the internet so here and there
I'll pop in and I'll check in just to
see in real time what's going on because
I can't like live
in a fairy tale land where everything's
okay but I do trust my team in my squad
so I don't really have to subject myself
to the ignorance of the internet but I'm
able I'm taking the [__] over right now
because
I'm investing
in the things that matter most the fans
and myself so I used to want to be so
cool
and I used to want people like like nah
but the music like listen to the music
like it's all about the music it's
actually has like nothing to do with the
music I make incredible music but the
reason I am as big as I am and as big as
I am [__] about to get I'm about to
be rap Secrets [__]
you don't understand like I'm about to
do it and all I'm gonna do is be myself
bro I'd be talking about the wildest
[__] I talk about when I got by my
[__] dad's mom sticking Skittles down
my throat I talk about the time I
experimented when I was like 12 almost
13 I jerked my friend off and he jerked
me off and I was like Ugh
yeah well I'm definitely not gay man
yeah you know but it's like my shoulder
yeah
there's a lot going on
but what I mean is think about how many
men
are like scared especially in hip-hop to
be like man I never touch no dick man
and it's just like what it's not that
deep well we're gonna talk about all of
it but it was a little deep no I'm just
kidding anyway
um all right you're very comfortable
with yourself are you a crier
look at you
how old your son three all right yeah so
what what I what it's like moments you
know it's like moments when you realize
like uh
you know damn you know I did it like I
my son is healthy and he's alive and
he's not like me he's not in a crack
house surrounded by drugs and guns and
violence and domestic abuse and murder
like wow and that'll make me emotional
to see this beautiful little boy or the
fact that I [__] love my wife so much
like I I love her and I I'm just so and
it's not a farce
you know because I'm not like I'm not
like look how much I like I'm I talk
about it because I'm proud you know just
like [__] I talk about being black
all the time and it's like but I'm proud
and yeah and that is you know [__] like
that makes makes me emotional
um not so much negativity though
honestly like that one of my last really
big big cries I've had a few recently
one was let's go down memory lane I'll
give you the last two top top two cries
top two top three cries top three cries
that I can remember myself three cries I
stubbed the [__] out of my toe and I'm
scared terrible that's a dad joke ask me
to give you a dad joke give me a dad
joke will you give it back
hahaha
anyway uh my son being born
uh me marrying my wife well the second
one
uh I would say uh you cried a different
time the first one yeah I was like what
am I getting into no I'm just kidding
that's a joke
um
I released College Park my album
recently and it takes place in 2011 and
it's about me and my friends in a car on
our way to an open mic night now in 2011
I was homeless I didn't have anywhere to
live and my best friend Lenny let me
live with him and before I knew it a
year later I went from being homeless to
signed a million dollar deal with Def
Jam in one year all my friends out to LA
and 10 years later here I am so I
thought it'd be kind of cool you know
you think about these like biopics like
Eight Mile and [__] you know that's like
Loosely based off Eminem I was like
there's no nobody's ever really done a
biopic in like an album so I have all
this sound design
and something that not many people know
about I'm actually sitting on an album
called The Ballad of rooster Jenkins
which takes place in 1863 about a
runaway slave it's not that deep though
it's like rap Django it's like fun and
it's a it's a thing but um all the
incredible actors uh all the biggest
voice actors in the world Morgan Freeman
is
Joseph gordon-levitt's on it but it's
all about sound design so and trust me
this all makes sense
with uh you know JJ Abrams introduced me
to his uh one of his lead sound
designers who did all the Star Wars and
Star Trek sounds and I wanted to create
like an old radio Orson Welles radio
play kind of a fear side chats some
wildly you put it on and close your eyes
and you see it you know what I mean yeah
and so I started with that and that's
crazy but it's not out yet and then I
got another idea I was like man what if
I did what if I did this fun story where
I kind of take the listener back in time
with me and so it's about me and my
friends going to an open mic show and
all the shenanigans we get uh in on the
way there and is that College Park
Maryland that's College Park you're
rolling around them what PG County yeah
like go ahead Mo you already know what
it is what a deal what a deal
[__] from Baltimore or
something like that they do they do and
you know what else in Baltimore it's so
funny because I used to hang I used to
work and hang out with these Baltimore
black guys and DC black guys and they
have a different accent and Baltimore
black guys would always say Doug you
Doug bite you Doug bite oh yeah into DC
black eyes Blake what the [__] is that
dog yeah cause they don't say Doug don't
sound like a Nickelodeon show that's a
weird [__] accent yeah [__] as well
but I love it so do white people white
people had a horrible accent like he
he's going to college yeah you know
Billy he's gone wow they sound like
grown three-year-olds yeah logic's got a
new album coming out it's called College
Park it's called College Park huh yeah
but I would say I don't even know how
the [__] we got here how did we get here
I just went I just took like a Metro if
you were is College Park after uh you
said a story about rolling around back
in the day [__] was I saying we're
talking about going this open mic night
I know but why it was a whole thing you
were explaining why you had this whole
theme too I know but it was deep there
were two of them yeah who gives a [__]
no not who gives this [__] you said JJ
Abrams introduced you to the sound guy
who put an idea oh to make a biopic and
I feel like I feel like nobody had
really done that in hip-hop and I wanted
to do that yeah well no music and music
you're right nobody's really done a
biopic about their
their come up their life you know and I
thought that that would really be fun
and so here I am realizing that like
music
is my biggest I love it so much
um and now I'm just seeing like me just
being me dude is like winning and I
remember I'm not gonna lie one of my
older managers
years and years ago like 2014 2015 I
started doing YouTube videos and they
were like kind of popping but nobody
like no rappers or anybody was doing
that he was kind of like
you know you don't want to be the
YouTube guy
right like really you told me that and
it's like I was I kind of agreed at the
time because I was like I want to be
taken seriously as a musician and
there's a part of me that wishes like
damn what if I had done kept doing it
but there's also a part of me that's
like bro you can't live in the past
you're doing it now you're having a
blast
you're right where you're supposed to be
I agree so I'm happy to be here I think
I was still saying something else but I
can't remember I wanna let's talk about
this then you want to do a biopic in
music let's talk about your life you're
born in
um Maryland you're born and raised in
Maryland yeah born born in Montgomery
County Maryland in Gaithersburg and uh
black father white mother both addicted
to crack and you know drugs and
different stuff like that met each other
on a bender as Theo put it
and they uh yeah they knew each other
for three days had sex on a crack house
floor made me is that popped out they
told you that yes yeah my mom did my dad
my dad kept it 100 are you an only child
no I'm one of nine nine yeah but I'm the
only child between my mother and father
okay and the only one who looks white
really which is wild yeah
that'd be treated differently
um no really no like the internet's lame
like like but in real life it's like I
was always just
it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't nothing
like if I switched to school like
everybody knew I was mixed right so a
little biracial little black looking
white boy
um but if I switch schools
you know I'd walk out on the playground
and I hear you know I see like the
brothers you know I'm like oh let me go
see what's up to the brother and I hear
somebody like oh it's a white boy let's
kick his ass I'm like where is he at
where's he at let's get him and they
start punching me in the face so I'm
like what the [__]
and I'm looking at my [__] I'm looking
at all my other brothers and sisters and
I'm looking at me and I'm like did y'all
leave me in a house fire what the [__]
but now I'm just kidding but but it was
one of those things where
when I would mean when I would meet kids
and they're like oh what's up white boy
and I'm like no I'm not I'm not white my
dad's black and he like
you sure you sure and I'm like yeah and
they're like all right my man that's and
that was it that is that that's all it
ever was so that and then um you know
grew up on welfare food stamps section
eight
uh and are your parents together for a
while while you're young or not at all
[__] no like I have I have I have like
one memory of them actually being
together and I have a picture of it and
it's my mom she's giving me this like
little Fried Chicken
and my dad's the one who took the
picture and um
yeah but that didn't work you know
because my dad was a crackhead like you
know and my mother was a recovering drug
addict and alcoholic and she you know
she struggled with her addiction my
whole life
um sorry am I too far away from the
microphone yes hello and
um
so that was a hard thing to see and then
she was also like super religious but
like the
the
hypocritical religious you know what I
mean like don't take the lord's name in
vain God damn it yeah well they're all
hypocritical in a way yeah and I'm like
for me I don't judge anybody I'm just
not a big organized religion guy it's
just not
like white jesus on a cloud it's like
that's not what I really picture when I
think about God well it ends up in
usually like mass murder and [__]
kids that's what organized religions
yeah so I'm really about people's
personal relationship with with whatever
yes so you could believe in whatever the
hell you want and I'll respect that I
just don't know why we all got to just
be gutting each other you know there's
this uh this episode of Family Guy that
I watched years ago and it was so
incredible
it's like the Middle East the year zero
this area and there's these two Middle
Eastern guys and one guy's like oh my
God I love you we've known each other
forever and he's like I know we're best
friends since childhood and then the
other guy's like man our kids play
together and he's like they're best
friends and he's like our wives love
each other he's like our wives are the
best and then this third guy jumps in he
goes hey man did you guys hear about
that magic baby that was just born in a
manger and the one guy goes oh my God
that's incredible I'm gonna follow that
now and the other guy goes I don't
believe in that that's not right and
then they start stabbing each other with
swords to death yeah
and it's just so crazy to me that like
the world is so divided and so angry all
the time and don't get me wrong man we
be passionate I've raised my voice in
arguments and XYZ and I get that but
it's just crazy that people really just
it's just like if you're a Christian and
you're atheist then everybody wants to
kill each other I don't know why it's
usually actually it's atheists that
don't want to kill anybody you know what
I mean but anyway yeah hot take so what
age do you realize [__] I need to really
fend for myself and take care of myself
on how quick six first grade yeah seven
early on you know yeah and what do you
why how do you know because my mom's
going to insane asylums and I'm alone
for two weeks yeah your dad's not even
around no he's smoking crack
you know what I mean like for real like
I've seen my dad smoke crack I remember
walking in when my mom let him stay with
us for a little bit and I walk in the
bathroom and he was with deirdra the
woman who loved me she she it wasn't it
wasn't like crazy she didn't like stick
a thumb in my ass or anything she just
like kissed me with Skittles in her
mouth so that was weird how old was she
I don't know the [__] looked like a
deflated football though
she looked like she looked like a camel
like like if somebody just took a
camel's skin and just threw it on a
basketball court in Brooklyn and [__]
105 degree weather
and then draped it over Groot from
Guardians of the Galaxy that's that was
and then the [__] kissed me so that's
definitely molestation
yeah it wasn't like and she wasn't like
Stacy's mom she didn't have it going on
it wasn't like oh this is great yes all
the Skittles in your mouth spit Skittles
no she like had them and she like passed
them to you it's like ASMR and yeah she
passed them to me and you know she
passed me [__] Ginger ale's taste and
her mouth was like an ashtray and she
had that she had that lipstick that like
wasn't red but it wasn't purple but it
wasn't it was like weird
anyway my life's great that happened a
lot huh
um no a few times there was that there
was that and then there was like I mean
I remember being in the in the bed with
uh my sister and her boyfriend and I was
about seven and I didn't know what was
going on but he was forcing her to suck
his dick
in front of you well I'm sleeping to the
side but I'm hearing this thing because
he's punching her in the face holy [__]
and he's like you gotta suck it better
[__] suck it better and he's punching
her and I'm like waking up from this and
I'm not understanding what's going on
and then I'm kind of grasping it but I'm
this little tiny boy who doesn't know
how to defend his sister or yourself
like but I don't and then she gets out
and she screams Mommy and she runs
out and then I just remember like
falling asleep again in the me in the
bed with this dude but it wasn't like
that and then the next day being like
why did she
come out screaming what happened and
then my mom was like oh she was just
really hot
so I don't know if she told my mom she
was really hot or I don't know if what
because then the guy wasn't there
anymore and that's one of the guy one of
the first guys who ever put a gun in my
hand as well so it was just
it was a while it was been a wild ride
yeah so let's stay to where we are we're
five years old six years old you realize
I gotta take care of myself so what is
Elementary School like are you skipping
school because you don't have to be
there yeah no not Elementary School
um when did things start shifting for
you they start shifting when my my
mother uh so I I was I was a pretty bony
kid and I remember uh they they were
saying that like I was always so fidgety
but it was just because I was bony but
they thought I had an attention problem
so they tried to put me on drugs and
that wasn't good it made me feel really
weird I remember saying that and then uh
my mom you know she would come in
because we didn't have any money and
start crying and talk about all the time
she'd been ripped and like all this [__]
to like yeah like the principal and all
this stuff so they're like yo this kid's
[__] up but like I wasn't I don't know
how I wasn't but I was all right but
they were like I mean he's got to be
right he's got him so then they put me
in this like a class for the emotionally
disturbed
and I'm like yo these kids are [__] up
I'm like yo these kids are [__] up
like honesty got a helmet yo for real
you're just emotions they had this
[__] they had this room called ASC it
standed for something confinement like
solid something solitary confinement
bro
I'm eight solitary can I find it I'm
eight years old and so you got all these
[__] kids who are [__] and I
can't defend myself because if I do I
further prove the point that I'm a
disturbed child right and you're aware
of that at that age dude 100 it's weird
I was aware of a lot yeah and and my mom
she
saw how much this was affecting me so
she was like all right I'm gonna
homeschool you
now her definition of homeschooling
is a six-pack and Hooked on Phonics and
this is not a joke this is a very this
is not a bit
that's what she's so you know my mom
would get [__] wasted all night and
then I'd wake up at seven eight in the
morning she's asleep she sleeps till 3
P.M 4 P.M so I'd get up and I just skate
and I'd go skateboarding and I do all
this and
excuse me
I'm skating to kind of it's my only
release right I'm not doing drugs
because I'm too scared
you know and um
I lose like three years of my life
because I was homeschooled and I didn't
learn anything so I went from fifth
grade essentially this was
late later so I'm like 10 now
and I went from fifth grade to eighth
grade
and the government contacted my mother
and was like
you're not
homeschooling your child I mean the the
closest she did she made me this like
fake um
homeschool ID
and I actually went around the white
neighborhood
right across the street
and I would uh knock on people's doors
and ask them to donate to the poor
people of America fund and they did and
I didn't feel bad because I was a poor
person of America
and that's like the best scenario that
came out of me getting homeschooled was
just like
hitting the Good Humor ice cream truck a
couple times like for real
so then they were like you need to put
you they need to put your your son back
in school so she put me back in school
and guess where the [__] they put me
they put me back in the same class with
the same kids from three years ago
except now they got little muscles and
they're [__] [__] and like and
I'm in there and I'm doing decent and
then they give me this like emotional
aptitude test do they treat you like
look you're back [__] yeah they
treat you like that like what's up Bobby
you're back huh
yeah but what was crazy is I couldn't
they would still pick on me because I
couldn't do anything or I'd be proving
the point so I take this emotional
aptitude test and the teachers literally
go you never you were never Disturbed
they're like look at this because they
never gave me a test in the first place
they just said your mom's screaming
about getting raped and having abortions
and smoking crack and being a prostitute
and all this wild [__] so I was like oh
my God and all those things are true of
your mom yes back in her day and let me
just say that
I haven't spoken to my mother in over a
decade whoa and yeah I know we'll get to
that and uh I haven't spoken to my
mother in over a decade and at the end
of the day all the things that she has
done to me like forms of sleep
deprivation
um you know hit me with the hard R her
own son you know her all her kids yeah
for real all her kids yeah she's wild
yeah because of the systemic racism that
she went through as a kid I mean she
brought a little black boy home at 14
and they're like we don't mix with their
kind and this like messed her up on top
of her being said at five years old and
all these things that she that she told
me about that's what I mean it's crazy I
mean my mother was telling me stories
when I was seven years old about her
being surprised by two men who were
holding a butcher knife over a stove
until it was orange holding it to her
neck and she's like describing to me in
detail what it means to be summarized
all this other things and then going one
day when not if when a man whoops you
when you have to scream as loud as you
can that you have AIDS and he may stop
like this is the [__] my mom was saying
to me now mind you anything and
everything that you hear me saying about
my mother or my father or anybody is not
said with disdain it is said from a
place of of Truth and
some comedy
but all has been forgiven there but not
forgotten so with that being said
this [__] puts me back in regular
school
and I'm in this I'm with back with these
kids and I take this aptitude test
and they're like you're fine what the
[__] are you doing here and I'm like
thank God so the first thing I do is go
to the meanest bullies [__]
neighborhood and I was like what's up
now Daquan
get it no for real I'm like what's up
what's up let's go and he's like oh oh
you out now like that's what's up
like trying to be all cool and [__] I'm
like [__] you man in my mind but I was
also but I was also kind of like man
it's kind of cool that Daquan likes me
yeah but really he was just scared of me
though
because he knew and it was like a whole
thing anyway [__] the Quan
yeah [__] the Quan I'm rich now where
you at Daquan you ain't doing [__] no
I'm just kidding it's a joke I mean he
definitely ain't doing [__] but you know
it's all good I'm just being funny so
check this [__] out though so then I go
back to school but they put me in the
school
that I was in with the regular kids
before they put me in the bad program at
the other school okay and then I got
homeschooled and then came back to the
[__] up program about four years from
these kids and it's like I'm a legend
like I come back and like all these
little little you know 13 year old girls
are like oh there's like there's like
Whispers like Bobby went to prison
[__] you know yeah I'm like yeah [__]
yeah I did I got a tattoo I can't show
you though
I can't show you you know what I'm
saying so that was that was kind of fun
it was cool to kind of be popular and
then I just became just a little skinny
Bobby again and and that was and I got
to be pretty normal which was cool so
now you're getting older and everything
and you can start to take care of
yourself uh driving does that change
your life or you get like get the [__]
out of home driving are you kidding me
are you joking I didn't have a [__]
license I was 26 years old for real 26.
for real I feel I felt like you would
have got one right away just so you'd
have some kind of Freedom what the [__]
away food stamps food stamps I'm gonna
buy a car with food stamps [__]
what did you mean you could steal them
you know how to drive no exactly my
brothers were doing that I am licensed
yeah exactly
um here's my license to send me to jail
so when does when does rap and wanting
to rap in her life is that in high
school is that later I think anybody
um
anybody who does what they do right you
know painter
comedian writer
filmmakers we kind of always have done
that thing our whole lives in one way or
another whether it's
you know making movies on VHS or
studying every film ever like Quentin
Tarantino like that's what we do you
know
um and in many ways we also cope and I
think that hip-hop for me was
not really an escape it was more of
actually a place where I was able to
deal with my problems by writing them
down
but that was also really difficult
because I would write down
and I'd be like man I'm trying to make
it out this [__] I'm trying to get out
of it I'm trying to debt it whatever I
know my mother's like don't you [__]
cry
it's like a [__] dementor from Harry
Potter she's like a [__] like Banshee
so when she screams it's like in beds in
your soul
and um that was really hard because here
I was trying to express myself and she
was telling me that I couldn't in a very
hypocritical way I mean I remember the
first time my mother found condoms I was
a virgin and she found condoms in my
backpack and she goes
what are these what are these and I'm
like
I'm like you obviously don't know what
they are because you have like six kids
so okay I'm like
they're condoms
all right and I'm like and I'm like [__]
and in my mind I'm like oh my God I'm
like why am I having this conversation
and and she's like I'm like I got him
she's like why do you have them and
we're walking to the store so it's like
eight miles to the store that's a joke
but it's definitely like a two mile walk
through there and back so four miles
damn that's actually a lot of [__]
miles that's a lot of miles
so we're walking and she's like how
could you have these and I'm like
because
um I don't want AIDS
or a sexually transmitted disease and
she was like don't use them and I'm like
what she's telling you know she's
telling me not to use condoms and I'm
like why and she goes because abstinence
is the only condom You'll Ever Need and
I'm like
I don't have a [__] chastity belt on
I'm a human being you know and I live in
the [__] real world so I'm like at
some point this is gonna happen
and
um she's just like you know what would
God say and all this [__] I'm like what
would God say about you [__] that
dude from the bus stop last week
you think I'm joking from the bus stop
I'll never forget it she wakes the fish
wakes me up two in the morning why are
you getting woken up drug into this now
two in the morning no this is this
actually this is a different time from
when I was younger I was 10 but this is
one of the times
that she had some bus stop sex so she
she wakes me up I'm like 10 years old
it's two in the morning and she she's
like I want you to meet someone very
special and I'm like okay and so I walk
out it's just like nerdy looking black
guy and he's like 20.
and she's like you know this is Muhammad
and I'm like okay nice to meet you and
she's like I met him at the bus and he
is an angel and I'm like okay
and then she's like now you may go back
to sleep so I go to sleep I wake up
completely forgot all that [__] I
thought I had a nightmare mm-hmm I wake
up I walk in I'm like oh man it's like
Saturday I'm about to [__]
well I don't have cable so I'm just
walking watching some PBS [__] but
I'm like all right this is gonna be
great and I remember I was so hyped
because my mom got the off-brand Captain
Crunch
instead of the kicks because kicks are
[__] lame chicks I remember kicks
that hard yeah why don't you kick rocks
[__] how about that it's a
terrible cereal so I'm like it's like
eating like newspaper so I'm like all
right I'm gonna go [__] this off brand
Captain Crunch in the butt and I go into
the
kitchen and it's [__] Muhammad eating
my [__] and I was like no way Muhammad's
real and for that's the first thing I
think and then this guy lived with us
for like three weeks and he's [__] my
mom and don't oh don't even get me
started on time I heard my mom getting
[__] in the ass when I was like 16.
that was we'll get there where were we
where mohammed's eating your [__]
your captain Munch up yeah but oh yeah
and that was just one of the captain
Munch
yeah that that was the
um
Admiral current crunch that was the that
was the first time or one of the first
times my mom started bringing juice home
from
but what a power play though I I would
never have the balls to come home I
would be like don't don't bring your son
out here and even if she did I I would
not spend the night and be there in the
morning when you got up and eat in your
Captain Crunch that is a move
that's a move man but he ain't got
nowhere to go still
he could leave he'd go outside you know
what I mean outside's free I'm also not
mad at that guy you know he was just
trying to get some [__] man I'm not
yeah but why you got to be drug into
this Welcome to My Life why do I have to
be drugged into half of this [__] that
was you know what I mean like so you're
hearing that [__] go on in the house
then too while you live with you said
you heard her have anal sex yeah she was
smoking boat uh that's PCP so she was
smoking PCP this is back when her and my
brother were smoking PCP together and
what are they dipping cigarettes and how
they smoking so for those of you out
there who don't know us embalming fluid
literally and they they'll dip it they
keep it in the freezer because it
doesn't freeze over and they would smoke
that and then there was just like we're
a super gangster dude and this is so my
mother she would go through these spurts
you know she would go through these
different uh times of like Holiness and
then you know one minute she's singing
you know our father and then the next
she's like me Nirvana like I'm serious
I remember man my mom when uh and we'll
get back to the anal
I remember when I was in high school I
was in ninth grade and my mom literally
was like I'm giving up my style for the
Lord first thought what style
because she just used to wear black all
the time and she started um
wearing like Mother Teresa type [__]
like all white wool looking
you know whatever and so she's like you
know I've given everything to Christ and
so she's coming to my school
you know almost like damn you're looking
like Muslim or something you know
like with a hijab but she's got this
whole thing division it really looks
like Mary Magdalene like everything yeah
I remember I actually arms in the sleep
yes I used to I used to put it on and be
like I'm the ghost of Christianity look
at me like I used to it was really funny
but the thing is it's like you know you
had all these other kids right who
um you know I'm sure they were a little
embarrassed you know that you you'd have
a
different denominations and races and
you know they all wanted to fit into but
back then you can't stand out and here's
my mom in a [__] duvet cover
you know what I'm saying I'm serious
like like just so annoying
no there's no buttons dude there's like
safety pins and [__] do you think I'm
joking
all right so anyway oh man so she'd have
a mood like that and then she'd be on
like some gangster [__] she's like I'm
listening to rap and getting [__] in
the butt
you know what I'm saying for real and
she didn't really remember it all but I
remember hearing it and I was like man I
gotta get out of here
and um that was just a difficult time
bro there's so many instances but once
again I'm not here I'm not [__] on
my mom I'm simply telling my story you
know sometimes my family they'll say
things to me they'll be like
you know they'll kind of be like hey man
why'd you say that I'm like why did you
do that
that's the real [__] question you
know what I mean hey Dad why did you
steal my identity when I was 10 years
old because we have the same exact same
name and max out credit cards and ruin
my credit before I was a [__] of age
why did you do that and he's like
well you didn't have to say [__]
literally that's my dad he's like you
don't have to say it
I don't even
anyway yeah welcome to my [__] life
let's talk about him for a minute how
what how much of a presence was he in
your life is he in your life at all now
what you know what he's like you ever
seen um Larry David do guest spots on
Seinfeld yeah you never really see him
you know once here over there he's like
you know steinburner's voice when
Costanza is working for the for the New
York uh Yankees that was my dad
it's like you just you you kind of got a
sight here and there and he's always put
yeah like Bigfoot yeah it's like blur
like the memories are all blurry of him
but you know he'd show up he'd like have
a suit
and you just like fly like he was just
like look at me I'm in my suit he pull
up in a [__] Honda Civic
and he's just that dude man you know
what I mean but it's like really looking
back I'm like man
that's pretty impressive you smoking
crack but are you walking around wearing
suits actually like congratulations I
don't know how you keeping that up but
he
he was never there for me I never had a
I never had a moment you know and not
not even to try to sound no type of way
I'm gonna be dead serious because me I
actually just reconnected with my father
recently you did yeah I'm always drawing
lines with my with my dad there's always
like I'm like hey these are the
boundaries and he goes vote in
boundaries like I'm like he would all he
would because he hasn't done it this
time it's like 38. 38 times I'm giving
them
38 chances literally I remember I told
him he was like let me just get one more
like every time he'll literally be like
let me get one more though but does he
genuinely want one more
I think my dad is just uh you know he's
68 man he's been through a lot he smokes
a lot of crack he's done a lot of things
that he's not proud of he's got nine
kids uh well technically because I'm the
only child between my mother and father
so he has four kids that I know of two
of my older twin brothers two sisters
and then I mean he was like Tyler Durden
from Fight Club set up franchises and
[__] just going all the way around hey
I'm serious it's just
all over Maryland he stayed local it's
just the welfare franchise no this
[__] was in like Philadelphia
went to Florida
I definitely got some white I got some
siblings somewhere you know anyway
athletic greens is back I first heard
about athletic greens and then I decided
to give them a try because I wanted to
improve my gut health and get my immune
system a little extra support it's all
your key Health Products like
multivitamins minerals pre and
probiotics and more working together as
one I added ag1 in my morning routine
and it really does leave me feeling like
I'm doing something good for my body
like covering my nutritional basis I'll
say this in the hospital I would you
know you all saw that food I would just
put some ag1 in water and boom take care
of myself right there it's made with 75
high quality vitamins minerals and Whole
Food sourced ingredients that deliver
benefits like mood immune system and
sleep support sustained energy and so
much more you can even get it in
convenient travel packs for when you're
on the go like I'm gonna use for my next
upcoming tour so if you want to take
ownership of your health today is a good
time to start athletic greens is giving
you a free one-year supply of vitamin D
e and five free travel packs with your
first purchase go to athleticgreens.com
honeydew that's athletic greens.com
honeydew check it out this is a public
service announcement manscape now has
beer products and is going even further
with their brand new weed whacker 2.0
that's right the leaders in below the
waist grooming are traveling north of
your South Pole with their revolutionary
products the new weed whacker 2.0 and
their new beard line confirms they have
all the best tools for your hygiene
toolbox time for you to upgrade your
game by going to manscape.com and using
my code honeydew for 20 off plus free
shipping the beard hedger Pro kit is the
ultimate package that makes it easier
than ever to craft your signature look
it all starts with the cordless electric
beard hedger this waterproof cordless
trimmer has a rotary wheel that gives
you 20 hair cutting lengths all with one
guard the pro kit also comes with four
dermatologist tested formulations for
your post trim Care Plus the kit has
three free gifts a beer brush comb and
scissors and to take care of those tough
to trim ear nose hairs is the brand new
weed whacker 2.0 it offers improved
blades and skin safe technology with a
no tugging guarantee so get 20 off and
free shipping with my code honeydew at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use my code
honeydew always use the right tools for
the job with manscaped I recently took
uh Kirsten her husband Derek my stepson
all to the we wanted to go see the
king's play we wanted to do something
different I wanted to thank them for
everything they did at the hospital and
I was having a a heck of a time finding
tickets and
um we just got this new sponsor game
time and I use them and it was awesome
it was fast and easy to buy tickets for
all the sports there's music comedy and
theater wherever you are with killer
Diaz on last minute tickets and their
best price guarantee you can stop
stressing over the tickets and start
getting excited for the fun you'll have
the game time app makes it insane
insanely easy to buy tickets for any
event in your area once you open the app
you can sort by popular events in your
area by event type whether it's sport
music or whatever you can do it by venue
and they even have the category of
events under 50 bucks so you can find
something to fits your budget it's the
fastest growing ticket app in the
country for a reason you get images of
your seat before you buy so you know
exactly what to expect when you arrive
you can buy tickets in a matter of
seconds two Taps boom boom and you're
set tickets are sent directly to your
phone so you never have to dig through
your email snag the tickets without the
stress with Game Time download the game
time app create an account and use code
honeydew for twenty dollars off your
first purchase terms apply again create
an account and redeem code honeydew for
twenty dollars off download game time
today last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed now let's get back to the do
so what was I saying you're talking
about your dad I know but I was saying
uh the chances and so like a couple
years ago I let him back in my life I'm
like don't be asking me for money
because I remember one time he's like oh
I was gonna I was gonna actually give
him like I bought my brother a truck
and then my dad thank you and my dad I
mean I've done a lot for my family I've
done a lot for people that aren't in my
family and I really aren't [__] cheat
they're these days and I don't talk
about it because I'm not the guy I'm not
the rapper that's like Hey Y'all we
handing out turkeys in the hood this
year for Thanksgiving and then he leaves
for 364 days
and then comes back again with like 800
in turkeys and then that's it like I'm
not that guy
you know it's honestly if I'm being real
it's a it's a big reason why I never
showed
my family like that because you know
people like you ain't black
and I've never been like yeah this is my
dad
I'm not trying to exploit my people of
color just to prove at the same time but
tell me about your dad now is he clean
now
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what did
he end up doing with himself
businessman you say wearing a suit what
did he end up doing for a living and
stuff smoked crack the whole time yes
but worked also no oh no my dad my dad
has never had a job in his [__] life
what the [__] my dad is the laziest guy
he's the Daniel ocean you've seen
Ocean's Eleven yeah yeah my dad okay is
the Daniel ocean of laziness like he
goes out of his way there's like schemes
he's like taking red string and like how
can I not work hard and he's working so
hard to not work hard not working hard
that's my dad but now these These Days
he's um you know he's living off Social
Security and [__] like that or trying
you know but I'm gonna see him I haven't
seen him in years and I'm actually
flying him out you know flying in first
class and I want him to meet his
grandson that's good so he's never he's
never met my boy that's what changed me
too with uh my mother I reconnected with
her when I was 40. or 40 no I'm lying 42
3 and because of my daughter well
um but let's talk about your mom again
now you haven't talked to her in 10
years why the last time I spoke to my
mother uh it was my birthday so it's
actually over that what what am I I'm 33
I was 21 so was that 12 years
um I just remember my sister calling me
crying hysterically and she was like and
I hadn't talked to my mother in a couple
years already
and she was like Mommy says that I'm the
reason that you don't talk to her and
blah blah but just some just some real
ignorant poor people [__] so I'm like
I call her and I'm like Mom I [__]
love you but the reason I don't talk to
you is because of you not because of
anything else because of you because not
even what you've done to me but what you
still do everything is your way
everything is your way of the [__]
highway everything is like like for
example like I was saying earlier like I
could not go to my mom and be like I
don't believe in religion I don't
believe in Jesus I don't believe in this
I believe in something right there she'd
be like you're going to hell [__] you
that's it done
like I can't talk to somebody like that
and over the years I've even asked my
brothers and sisters who do talk to her
like hey like how is she like should I
and they're like don't
they tell you that they literally
they're like and there's been times when
I I found that I had her number or
somehow got something and I would hit
her up and be like I would call
and that it would be disconnected or go
to voicemail or something would happen
to
get in the way and I think in a good way
because my she's really the type of
person that like if I introduce my wife
to her like within moments she could
just be cursing her out and screaming at
my child like that's the type of person
she was
um but once again this is all the
sickness my mother's bipolar damn near
schizophrenic so she said she really did
go to mental oh yeah bro she was getting
locked up in mental asylums and would
you go visit her no no no I mean I'd
visit she would take me to visit like
her men in prison and [__] like that for
real sneak stuff in yeah get the [__]
out of here she's taking you to do that
yeah and I mean it's an all-day event
too once again bro we don't have a
[__] car
can't buy a car in food stamps so we're
taking like three Metro buses and the
train and you know all this all this
other stuff to go to prison and I don't
know why because I'm just trying to
watch SpongeBob
trying to be a kid yeah but it was hard
to be a kid it's hard to be a kid when
your mom's training you a [__] media
press for when the social worker comes
over well it's also hard to be a kid
when you have to be the adult in a
relationship and you've been that since
day one yeah you really have
you know you can't even have all right
so let me ask you this then when do you
realize like you need some therapy and
have you gone to therapy what do you do
do you Journal do you meditate what do
you do to [__] deal with you the
anxiety that all this life brings I
um I then use music and writing
and I still do that to this day but you
know when I was like 24 that's when I
got a legitimate therapist and I made
you do that I just wanted to I was like
I should speak to somebody I should just
do it again the stigma of a man going to
therapy didn't bother you like a lot
that's that's a big part of the state I
think a little bit because it was like
oh you in therapy was wrong right like
what's wrong with you it's like nothing
yeah nothing's wrong nothing I'm just
talking to somebody I got some [__]
going on but then like when I started
making my therapist cry I was like I
need somebody
yeah like I'm not even joking I was like
I need somebody else
you don't understand this [__] was like
give me survive season Trend or
something yeah because she was like oh
my God what the [__] and I'm like
telling her [__] and she's like I am so
sorry for you and she's like you deserve
everything you have you deserve the
world and I'm like
let's see Lady yeah yeah I'm like so can
you give me 150 for this yes but then I
found
I found my therapist that I've I've seen
for the last five almost six years and
she's she's just uh armed me with such
incredible tools of how not to cope but
how to heal you know and how to actually
deal with uh what's going on in my life
and through that I've I've found so much
out about myself
and what I mean just like uh you know
I'm damn near a hypochondriac but a lot
of those things are really just
intrusive thoughts and intrusive
thoughts in and of themselves like you
could think about I don't know stabbing
an old lady who's a cashier in the
throat with a knife and you're like what
the [__] I was actually talking to uh my
godparents about this last night
and most people could some people
watching or listening could be like I've
never thought about anything like that
and it's like yeah but you thought about
some [__] and it's stuff that we are
actually so scared and it could be so
despicable and so disgusting that we
wouldn't even want to say it out loud
because it's not our thoughts though a
lot of people think when those thoughts
come into their head like how could I
think something like that oh my God oh
my God I can't tell anybody and then
they start freaking out and as soon as
they freak out they're training their
brain so then they start thinking about
it more because they're sending this
like trauma alarm in their head off like
oh my God I can't believe I thought
about kicking a baby oh my God and it
really actually tends to be that that
our intrusive thoughts are the things
that we care about most actually
and at the end of the day the thing that
makes us us and not Jeffrey Dahmer is
like we don't act on those things we go
oh my gosh and we cast it aside and so
the same could be said about health
anxiety about anxiety in general when
you ruminate so rumination and
constantly thinking about that thing
that's where it lives breathes you're
feeding this whether it's fear whether
it's you know
um maybe you do have like a bit of a
pain in your arm but as soon as if you
go it's cancer it's cancer as soon as
you do that to yourself
you can't do that and a big thing that I
was doing for a long time was
reassurance seeking so it's a cycle
something could happen for example yeah
so I I definitely have health anxiety
but oh my God night and day from
literally even a year ago I would always
be like I feel weird I feel out of it
like even even right now I feel a little
I feel a little
here or there I might have a moment of
like I feel a little dizzy it's happened
once while we're talking or I'll feel
whatever and there's all these things
like bro [__] lights on me millions
of people are gonna hear this and see us
all over the Internet that's a lot of
pressure and and so for me to go
it's okay you're okay and also the
content you're talking about oh it's
very it's not we're not just sitting
here making jokes you're talking about
real [__] molestation all that yeah and
so with that
I used to feel weird all the time so
then I go to people like I feel weird do
you think I'm okay and I would ask my
wife like do you think I'm okay and she
was always there for me I think you're
fine sweetheart I think that and my
therapist taught me like stop doing that
because realistically she your wife
doesn't [__] know if you're okay good
boy yeah you could even go to a doctor
and be like am I okay yeah they'll
misdiagnose you yeah they could look at
you and be like oh yeah your heart's
good everything's great and you have a
[__] heart attack
I have to say I I had a problem
my daughter almost got hit by a car and
it would have been brutal
and I talked to Dr Drew about and he's
like have you ever done EMDR therapy and
I said I heard about this done talk
therapy he's like no this is a very
specific kind of therapy and there's an
end to it I was like great now some
people get there quicker than others it
could be years it could be months for
someone else but
um told me about this it's let me tell
you something it changed my life because
I'm a little scared this is some L Ron
Hubbard [__] no not at all sure I
promise I've done it and I do it it's
what I said to her was I can't stop
thinking about what didn't happen I
couldn't stop seeing my daughter get hit
by this car and then this image of this
mangled just God forbid because it
wouldn't have been up and and she was
how old oh man that time she's about
five wow she was just running a kid she
just came right out to the street by us
and this guy came Fallen ass but wait he
was too close but still she if she'd
took another step it's over and I
grabbed her and pulled her back and my
goodness and then I yelled you know and
then I calmed down right away and you
know if but but it [__] me up and I
got scared to start flying I gotta fly
from my job you know how much you fly I
don't fly as much as you fly but I gotta
[__] fly I had the craziest fear of
flying we'll get there let's please
continue but I used to love it I used to
feel like a rock star [__] going down
that Runway and taking off then all of a
sudden I was like Jesus every bump I'd
be like huh inside oh God I beat any
turbulence terrified never bothered me
before I used to sleep through it and
it's like you're gonna die like in your
head you're like
yeah it's still in my mind yeah but she
taught me tricks about things like
monkey Taps and I'll say she you mean
the person that the therapist yes okay
yeah
um and also just not future tripping
future tripping no thank you what a
beautiful yeah I know about that that's
just that's what we're doing we're it's
not real right now it's but you're
conditioned because of your trauma and
the way you've been as you just said
don't do that don't put yourself in that
it's cancer because once you do it's
worst case scenario every time glass
half empty glass half empty and
um I also got scared and I still feel
like this is realistic uh scared of
heights I had never been scared of
heights before but still a realistic
height I'm still like I ain't going out
on that balcony [__] that [__] we're up
20 how many floors 20. [__] that I don't
need looks nice from here I don't need
that
um but flying I got over now I sleep on
my flights I'm I'm out I used to be that
way I almost bought a [__] tour bus
you going John Madden everywhere yeah
literally I was so
scared
and I never wanted that you want to know
what [__] did it Paul Rothenberg my
[__] attorney that's who did it you
[__] [__]
I'm sitting there I'm having uh I'm
having dinner with him
and
this is like 2013.
and we're just talking you know he's he
educates me he's a great he's a great
attorney he taught me so much about the
record business you know a lot a lot of
people like to keep uh keep their
artists stupid not this guy not my team
not my people is that right yeah why you
think I'm a [__] Walking Company yeah
yeah exactly and so
he he was like Hey man he's like wow
this uh this place is really good huh
this is my Paul Rothenberg question he
doesn't really sound like that but he
kind of does and I'm like yeah it's
really great he goes ah gosh I gotta get
on this flight tomorrow
there you go
oh yeah
I got a flight in a couple days he goes
yeah man
what a [__] flying death trap am I
right and I'm like what
I'm just 23 I'm like what do you mean
flying he's like yeah you're just in
this metal death machine you can just go
down at any minute you know I don't even
know how it gets in this in the air and
I'm like
okay whatever I finished my [__]
linguine
you know I'm doing press the next day
whatever then I get on an airplane I'm
on I'm fine take off everything's great
stick and beautiful and
night and I fall asleep
and then I just hear
flying metal death trap flying metal Dad
Trap like in my mind
and I wake up
and I just have the biggest panic attack
ever and I'm like oh my God this doesn't
make any sense this isn't natural
[__] are supposed to be on the
floor we ain't supposed to fly what is
going on you know spaghetti monster
would have gave me wings
yeah the Wright brothers were wrong
the Wright brothers were wrong Brothers
wrong yeah so so I'm like freaking out
bro like eight years
whoa like eight years how the [__] did
you you panicked for eight years did you
knock yourself out yeah no I never mind
you I didn't I didn't start drinking
alcohol or smoking weed until I was like
27. so because of my childhood seeing my
parents and you know struggle with all
that so I'm doing I'm white knuckling
literally I'm there like every flight
and I'm like shaking and just everything
and and then one day through therapy
I was just like bro I'm not in control I
have to relinquish control I'm not as
much as I want to be in control I'm not
in control no matter what it's not like
you can walk up there and tell that
pilot move dude let me do this like even
then it's like they want to get home
just as bad as I do do you know
hopefully hopefully it's not one of
those suicide I know exactly yeah
definitely yeah oh [__] yeah you don't
want one oh my God you think that could
happen do you think that could happen to
us I'm just kidding I'm just [__]
with you uh but no but so future
tripping is like you gotta that's a real
thing it's like why would you freak out
about something that has not happened
you know what will happen my son is
going to die yep my wife's gonna die I'm
gonna die you're gonna die we're all
dead nobody makes it out of life nobody
and
that's all right
it is what it is it's not supposed to go
and all we can do is focus on the now
and the present and do the best that we
can with what we have and and you know
that's why I kiss my wife every time I
leave and give her a hug and tell her I
love her and I kiss my son and you know
my best friends my [__] security
guard one of my best friends in the
world Jordan I give him a [__] hug I
tell him I love him before he leaves
every day like
these are the people that I care about
and and I'm feeling that hard right now
I after being in the hospital in January
for a month and almost dying it makes me
smile yeah I mean uh it made me really I
was already grateful I was journaling
every day about how I was grateful for
my health and my daughters every [__]
day and I was like God damn I really
feel like I put my time and effort in on
that Health [__] and then like the one
surgeon said he's like you didn't do
anything wrong this is just a genetic
thing and that's what happened blah blah
blah so after that you know you're
laying on your back I'm just starting
physical therapy now I'm telling you old
dudes are running laps around me now I
just got off a cane really yeah I was a
walker first then a cane
um but I feel you know mentally good I
can sit and do this I'm not going to
start touring until you heard my dates
Fort Wayne Indiana in May sometime I've
got a few months so I gotta let these
lungs and [__] heal up but you said
lungs what do you mean I had clots I had
ended up clotting him my lungs it's
called pulmonary embolisms and uh but
you smoke you know you're allowed to
smoke marijuana
now not allowed I'm gonna tell you this
this is this is what they say they told
me never smoke cigarettes no Vapes no
cigars no alcohol because I'm on blood
thinners for life four surgeons but you
can't drink they don't want me to drink
yeah that sucks but see I'm not a
drinker I'm a weed smoker and this is
what I kept saying to them in there is
this my end is this the end of the Run
am I going to Edibles what is going on
only smoke weed and I do a little bit of
shrooms that's it and they said I
haven't done shrooms yet I can't wait
we'll talk it's going to change your
life that's what they say it's going to
change your life and um it's a great
reset it's just a great reset
um but they said those two things will
never hurt you and I said how can I fly
and how can I smoke marijuana with clots
in my lungs and they said that what you
have in your lungs it is what it is your
body will take care of it it could be up
to a year before your body gets rid of
these clots on its own then your lungs
are clear
but if you're gonna smoke anything again
there's a two-part message we don't ever
want you to smoke anything we're doctors
but if you're going to put anything in
your lungs it's cannabis and I was like
you got to be [__] kidding me and
they're they're like you can smoke and I
said I smoke a lot of weed [__] we know
we saw your blood test results and we
came in I said well that was five days
clean for the surgery and they go you're
nowhere near in any harm of doing damage
that's like the greatest news you could
have ever heard I couldn't get over it
and these are all different surgeons who
don't work with each other don't know
they told me this and [__] and I'm
recording them they don't know I'm
recording but I got that phone right
there on record and I'm like I Can Fly
And I can they're like yup you can do it
what are you in the wire are you apart
are you like a somebody from The Wire
you don't know I'm recording right now I
also wanted every [__] thing over
because you're so doped up on Dilaudid
and drugs
and they do that they you wake up at
five o'clock in the morning they go
Bobby we're going to tell you all the
most important information you need to
hear right now about your health care
and then and then they're out of there
sure I never talk [__] about anyone else
which I know I'm being recorded
Okay so
you did the surgery yeah you gotta pee
no Out of Water right here I did the
surgery two times I had to do this sir
oh my goodness because there was a tear
and then they let me lay there for a
while and that's how I ended up clotting
I knew I would because I had clauded
before but wait you clouded in your
lungs yeah so wait did they wait but I
thought it was a back surgery it was but
what ha so
in 2016 man we got to do all this math
now for this story I get diagnosed with
a genetic blood disorder right it's
called Factor five line it just means
that I have thick blood and it's prone
to clotting so I got to keep my machine
moving bed rest or anything like that
I'm in danger of dying because my blood
will clot
so how long have you had that it's since
birth it's a genetic thing but I don't
find out until I'm 40. because I my legs
started clotting and I was I was rubbing
my they like felt like they were itching
and I'm rubbing my jeans I'm like God
damn I can feel my veins through my
jeans so I call the hospital and they're
like sir you're clotting get here now
and I drove in there and it was a end up
being a whole thing from kidney stones I
go on bed rest I clot right
the thing is you could have this and
people have wait you had kidney stones
yeah did you piss them out yes ooh bro
all right we'll get there keep going so
this is crazy so all right we'll go
there so 2016 I get kidney stones and
they keep telling me you're fine you're
fine I'm like I'm not fine I start
clotting in my chest and I'm telling
them I'm going home they keep kicking me
out of the hospital telling me I'm wrong
and I'm like I'm not wrong
and I go home in this one night I lay on
my bed and I'm crying I give myself up
to whoever and whatever I I was like I'm
done this is exactly how my father died
I'm 42 same age this is real weird
parallels yeah I'm giving myself up
thank God I wake up and I just start
being diligent about this I'm like you
gotta [__] fix this and help me and
they end up helping me get out of pain
and realizing now that I've got this
blood disease and that's what had been
clotting me and everything else wow but
they don't put me on blood thinners so
fast forward to this surgery I'm telling
everybody in my paperwork before I go if
anything [__] happens trust me you
know that .001 I'm the [__] guy
that's me in that pocket that's what
this shows all the [__] about and
they do the surgery but there's a small
Terror and it starts ballooning up with
blood and they're like you just have to
come back in we got to cut you open fix
that tear but wait the tear is in your
back right my lower back okay this [__]
stamp area like a scar like that's my
[__] station Noise Okay I love it so um
they cut me open a second time but now
it's not healing so like just lay here
and relax I'm supposed to be there three
days max well three turns into four or
five I'm there wait like it's not
healing like it's together it's it
healed together but it's not the
swelling's not going down
hey you kept everything intact you know
right anyway I'm listening so um
I'm telling them and keep telling them
they do an ultrasound on my legs like
nah you're good the day I'm supposed to
get out it's literally MLK Day nice
um I have to pass a stairs test because
I have stairs going up into my place and
thank God something like that you don't
even think of the the fact that I got a
home that has stairs saved my life so I
go to do the stairs test I go up and
down now she goes go up sideways like
you're holding on a rail like this I go
up and down and the whole time I'm
telling her I feel different today I
just I can't put my finger on it but I
feel weird
and then she says literally her words
are Mr sickler as your occupational
therapist I can tell you that you have
successfully passed all the steps
necessary to go home today you're free
to go and I [__] collapse on the bed
and I'd say I'm clotting and she's like
what I go I'm clotting I've had before I
know it I'm in the doctor runs in he
does my blood pressure he's like you
might be having a heart attack and I was
like huh I go no this has happened I'm
clotting he's like tell me what you feel
I said I feel three elephants on my
chest and he goes keep talking to me and
as I'm talking I feel heart attack 101 I
feel the pain and I go here it comes
pain in the jaw it goes down my arm he
says you might be clotting and having a
heart attack and then I black out
and when I wake up there's a nurse
standing over me and I said am I going
home today she's like your discharge has
been canceled and I spent the next month
in the hospital trying to [__] live
because they were like you're not a
great and this is when this was just in
January
yeah I just started physical therapy I'm
so happy you're here me too this is wow
that's nice to see you thank you no but
that's a you know I'm happy I'm here
that's what I'm saying like I'm really
practicing gratitude now after all this
[__] you need another water I'm good
thank you Dan that's a crazy story man
it's it's and I can only imagine because
I'm gonna be honest I feel like you in
the sense of I'm really appreciative of
the days that I have and the people
around me and everything I don't love my
job I work for myself now but that's
also schedule that's also a thing to
also kind of teach you like
one don't future trip but
anything could literally happen at any
time so like the fact that in a month
from now
it could happen again
means you need to enjoy what you have
right now and but we can't freak out
because it you could live to your 90 and
be all right that's right you know and
why be miserable the whole time freaking
out about not living and you're like
damn I made it to 90. like I already
outlived my father that was a big deal
for me personally to pass an age but
also so young yeah even now I'm at 50. I
mean my back my knees don't agree with
me but I still I still feel like I'm in
my 20s that was one of my top cries tell
me so you talk about passing your father
at 42 when I turned 32 do you know who
Jay Dilla is the rapper yeah rapper and
producer yeah I do I've learned the name
yeah he passed away uh in 2006 and his
stamp on music let alone hip-hop is one
that will last forever his timing
signatures of his kicks and his snares
and his samples and he was in an
incredible group called um
slum Village one of my favorite albums
of all time fantastic Volume 2 with a T3
and Bot 10.
and I'd always known about Dillo and I'd
heard I'd heard Dilla beats my whole
life and you know on Commons albums or
this or that never really knew that he
did had done a lot of it and then I
remember when I was around 30 I started
really diving into the Dilla thing
because I wanted to really start
producing like really like focus on
production I've always produced but I
mean on my own I don't need another guy
playing keys I don't need another guy
like just me and I went down this J
dilla rabbit hole
everything you could know about him I
figured out and I learned and
he became such a part of me
and I turned 32 and I think about I
could I could cry right now think about
this is that because
um sorry man don't be you know because
this guy really changed my life bro
and he was 32 years old when he died and
he died of [__] this crazy blood
condition he had lupus and
he left you know beautiful children
behind sorry dude don't be it's just
difficult because I'm like this dude
like changed so much and here I am and I
was telling my wife this [__] and I was
just talking to her about how much I
love Jay Dilla
and then I was like and he died when I
was
when he was my age right now and it just
hit me in a way
because I think about how much he
accomplished by 32 how much I
accomplished by 32 I'm 33 now
but I think about how much I got left
and I think about the fact that that was
stripped from him and taken from him and
it makes me so [__] sad
and that was a really hard cry but it
was also a beautiful cry because I was
like I'm keeping this man alive yeah me
and many others like me who love him and
have been like
like
chiseled in how we create music because
of this man's Legacy so
that's what I'm doing with this that's
what I named my album Lefty son after my
I mean my special excuse me after my dad
this
my comedy you know keeps them alive so I
feel you on that and the other thing too
like his kids lost him and and I thought
about that in the hospital like I don't
want my eight-year-old daughter to be
without a [__] dad especially me I'm
a good dad like we get along great I'm
not like your dad yeah for sure you know
so let or my mom so let's talk about
that as a parent now do you find
yourself maybe over correcting a little
bit do you find your were you also
worried that it was genetic and that you
would be a shitty parent because I was I
was like [__] what if I'm like my mom
and not like my dad I couldn't imagine
it though and I'm not but were you ever
worried about that
I'll tell you genetically one thing I
was worried about in one second I
remember when
you know my wife's about to pop and I'm
talking to people you know throughout
the pregnancy and I'm just kind of like
I'm so nervous like I want to be a good
dad like I hope I'm a good dad and so
many people literally were like the fact
you think that means you're gonna be a
great dad that's good advice because you
actually care you're like think I'm
think I'm learning [__] swaddling and
all this [__] and like all this stuff
and I'm learning it
and the fact that I cared so much before
the baby was even here let me know like
dude my dad was not there when I was
born like you know what I mean it's
[__] crack like so it's like it's
like mission accomplished dude like you
already did you're already a better
father than yours was and your kid ain't
even here yet and when I was nice to
myself and was like dude you're gonna be
a great dad you're gonna [__] up you're
gonna make mistakes you might Raise Your
Voice one time you might do something
that
is gonna make you really sad or this or
whatever but like you're always going to
be a [__] good dad because you care
enough
now what scares me genetically right is
um
I could be the best dad in the world and
my wife could be the best ever but my
son is who he is as a person
and that scares me that he could become
a drug addict he could become a bully he
could become a criminal
he could become all the things that I
was destined to become
but averted
and that really scares me do I think
that he's gonna do that no I think he's
a [__] genius I think he's incredible
I think he's amazing
but I'm also not gonna be there every
second of his life so all I can do is
the best that I can to prepare him uh
for for that world and and just hope for
the best so that's that's very well said
I mean I'm having real life
conversations with my eight-year-old kid
about fentanyl it's real because you
have to that is there's kids in her
school whose older brother had already
passed from it
um they're doing commercials on TV about
it all the time so I'm like we're not
going to run from them we have friends
my my really really good friend's
daughter got a hot shot and she died and
you know she meets him and I ask him how
are you doing you know and he's crying
and I'm crying and she's like what
happened to his daughter and I was like
you know what I'm not gonna [__] lie
to you because this shit's real out here
like if you ever and they're designing
them to look like candy for kids and
[__] is wild right all right going back
to genetics though let's talk about you
had two addicts for parents
um how do you fight that have you ever
had the urge to go down that path or do
you like you said you didn't start
alcohol or weed until later because you
were cognizant of that but are you
battling it I drank I never remember
being drunk
I think the most I ever like as a
teenager and [__] like the most I ever
did was like chug a beer and a half and
maybe take a shot and literally like
literally just like went to sleep like
immediately
so I don't remember that and I was so
terrified that it would change me that
was the thing I was scared
excuse me that if I
drank alcohol it was going to change who
I was as a person in a bad way in a bad
way
same with weed so I definitely had my
fair share of smoking weed as a kid
nothing crazy but like I smoked it like
9th 10th grade that was basically that
was basically it and so 14 15 and I'd
skip school and [__] like that wasn't
that deep somebody definitely laced a
blunt one time I was with me a couple of
my homies and there was these guys who
sold in the weed and we were all
freaking out and kind of out of it I
think they might have like put some PCP
in it and learn something like wild and
um that was scary
um but
yeah I just knew I just looked at my
family not just my mom and my dad but
some of my brothers and sisters and was
like I don't want to be this and I also
didn't want to be on the other side of
it you know because my brothers had even
sold crack to our dad
you know which is oh yeah yeah you can't
make this [__] up no dude definitely not
so
that was like a wild thing you know what
I mean or or me learning how to cook
crack or you learned yeah yeah yeah when
I was a teenager well there was once
when I was younger but I didn't really
yeah and then there was another time
when I was like 18.
and I was at my sister's house and it
was just this whole process I talked to
Theo about it and it was like so so wait
you're touching you're handling this
stuff yeah but the elements you're
you're aware and present that the
elements around you enough that this is
going to destroy your life so even
though you're touching it and [__]
with it or whatever you're not using no
and I mean the smoke is billowing into
the vent of little girls rooms above us
and [__] like this is like a [__]
wild situation yeah
and at the time I was kind of cracks I
know exactly I was kind of like oh this
is cool I'm cooking crack you know but
then like I go downstairs afterwards and
I'm like
disappointed in myself I'm like why did
I do that like what the [__] is going on
so that's why a lot of people ask me
like how did you not
go down the same path how did you
whatever and I always say I don't know a
God in common sense I don't know there's
something in you though I know but
that's what I mean but I don't know what
it is I can't but guess what you know
what to me it's kind of like religion a
lot of people like my mom for example
like she needs Religion she she would
always say like if it wasn't for Jesus
Christ had it murdered a lot of
[__]
yeah and I know it I'm like oh my God
and I'm like
I'm really glad you believe in Jesus
like that's good for you and that you
have that and that you need that
um but I just
I don't know I just never needed
I just knew what to do like I didn't
need something to
believe in like oh I I'm gonna follow
God or a specific religion or blah blah
blah and because it says Thou shalt not
kill
I'm gonna really hold this urge not to
kill anybody it's like no morally that's
that's just who I am and and um
I I think a lot of people for example
you know who believe in a specific
religion once again I'm not [__] on
anybody here uh
that's my Jesus my Jesus
he went to dry bar
you got done up
but I know
that a lot of people are like
they want they need the answers so it's
like okay I followed this religion
because I have faith and I know that if
I do X Y and Z I'm going to heaven
that's how my mom was
and then I woke up one day and I
realized maybe there is no Heaven maybe
there is no God maybe this maybe that
what do I believe in
and I think the fact that I was like as
I just expressed to you I said I don't
know what it is inside of me that kept
me from doing those things I don't need
to know
a lot of people need to know I need to
know this is the thing for me and this
is that I don't need to know I'd like to
know I mean who would I mean I'd love to
know if there was aliens
you know what I'm saying all the ships
hovering around could you imagine like
an alien BJ it's probably amazing it's
probably out of this world you know what
I'm saying I come in peace
no anyway
no I really I it's something that's just
like I don't need to know that a lot of
people definitely feel like they need to
so even when I think about like you know
people would say things like how could
your mother be racist and call you the
n-word and XYZ like that doesn't make
any sense and I'm like I know
I'm not here to try to make it make
sense I'm it's a disgusting terrible
thing and that sucks that I live through
that and it is like I'm with you on that
sometimes you don't need to know why
sometimes you sleep better not knowing
why I resonate with that because
um whenever I step right before I go on
stage I always get nervous I get the
adrenaline yeah all that but the moment
I'm out there good or bad set yeah yeah
they're gone
and people have asked me like when I'm
like the moment I walk out there those
butterflies are gone why I don't know
and I say it all the time I don't even
want to [__] think about why it works
it's working the minute I start thinking
about why I might start [__] it up
you know what I mean getting in my own
way future tripping or tinkering this
and do that do that start no just leave
it alone I do that sometimes like I just
did Jimmy Kimmel and I I did this crazy
performance like like we start in this
like makeshift basement and then I'm
rapping like crazy I'm standing on a
[__] table like Kanye you know and
like and then we walk through and then
it's like this all the fans are there
it's live and then I make my way to a
stage and all this [__] and I remember
getting to this part
and it was this part that I wrapped a
million times a million times and I was
so scared I was gonna [__] it up and it
goes uh let me get up on an MPC when I
kind of making beats into MVP on the
main [__] you're an NPC get them
full of MV the boy from MD destroy what
I see deployed in IB to illusmc
braggadocious flow vein like an IV and
I'm all up in a system blink one singing
might have missed them pack a punch like
I'm Sunny listen better listen like I
always do the intuition never missing
unless I'm on tour than a family I miss
them come and get some money
but this was the first time I'd ever
done it live or yeah ever ever damn so
I'm like
don't [__] this up and as I'm walking to
the stage to do that part let me get up
on the MPC like I'm like oh [__] because
you gotta also understand like when I
memorize lyrics right my mom actually
taught me how to memorize
I was Shakespeare in a wax museum at
school and I had this like my frilly
little thing that I could read from and
it was like I'm William Shakespeare that
was the first line and the second line
was I was born in some [__] long time
ago and then the third line was whatever
and then she was like she would make me
do the first one I'm William Shakespeare
I'm William Shakespeare I'm William
Shakespeare I'm William Shakespeare I'm
William Shakespeare I'm William
Shakespeare over and over and over and
over and over and over and over and
[__] over and over bro and over and
over and over and over and over
over and over and over
and over and then she gave me the second
line and I was born in some [__] time
over and over
and we would do this over and over and
over until I knew every line because she
was like you're not reading some [__]
[__] piece of paper you're gonna know
this
and that's how I memorize rap lines to
this day now I'm just so much of a
professional at doing it doesn't take me
forever
but well Chris Rock just said he [__]
up a joke on that live Netflix he's like
all [__] up the punchliner I can't
remember what he said but you ever [__]
up in a way where people don't know you
oh that's all the time he never
accidentally drop a verse from another
song in this song or anything like that
I've never done anything like that but
I've just like [__] up and forgotten
but the thing is is I just I just have
ways to to go about it that the crowd
doesn't even know that I'll tell you
when the camera isn't even on because
but what I was gonna say is is that on
that specific thing I was so scared
because of the of the flow and the way
that I memorize is I actually don't
memorize words so I don't look and go
the Honeydew with like I don't do it
that way
it's all here so I've realized that it's
all no it's literally muscle memory it's
like a dance so if somebody does a
specific dance they do all that again I
just went to Bollywood real quick anyway
if somebody does a specific dance they
do it over and over so by saying it so
many times that muscle memory let me get
up on the NPC when I couldn't make it
I mean [__] you're an NPC got
them
and it's it's literally just the way my
tongue and lips and [__] teeth move
that I could wrap it without saying a
word but I couldn't sit here and go
let me get up on the NPC I don't know
what comes after that and that's just a
really weird way that I memorize my
shirt
um I want to ask you a few more things
before we wrap this up how do you deal
with anxiety today do you have time for
it just like lots of blow no I'm just
kidding
uh no yeah I'm good we're good on time
um
you just you obviously go to therapy
yeah I go to therapy I deal with things
head on I use my tools I really use my
tools you know a lot of people they they
tend to seek
help but then [__] will be like
don't do this do this and they're just
like what yeah like they just can't do
it and they don't do it and maybe
they're so stuck in their ways that they
just refuse to do it even though they
they're they're calling for help and
that's cool but I'm not here to pull
teeth you know and
that's kind of how I am in my life and
with the people that I keep around me
it's like
especially now because I've I've not I I
haven't helped I've helped a lot of
people but I've also enabled a lot of
people and done a lot of things for them
because I just wanted them to make it or
and you can't do that you can't not you
cannot do it for someone so for me when
it comes to anxiety and dealing with it
it's those tools you know uh don't
ruminate over things don't don't body
check don't ask for uh you know
reassurance don't re don't don't use
forms of reassurance seeking don't uh uh
yeah ruminate and overthink on those
thoughts whether they're intrusive or
thoughts about bills or money or this or
all these other things man like you have
to let all that [__] go and if if you
[__] snap your arm in half then you
can freak out and go oh [__] you think
I'm gonna be all right doctor like
that's it you know legit yeah that's
real but if you're like
oh my heart's beating kind of fast do
you think I'm okay it's just like you
gotta let that [__] go so I'm using I'm
using my tool and I'm not perfect I'm
[__] far from perfect bro I'm [__]
up you know what I mean like yeah me too
I'm [__] up yeah but
I think I'm a pretty good [__] you're
a pretty good [__] up
all right last question before I ask
does it have to be the last one though
what okay okay just saying um eight
inches no I'm just kidding okay
what um when did you know when did you
feel the shift from
four to you know the level you're at now
when did you feel it do you mean do you
mean in my career or in my personal life
in my career the shift wow well there's
I feel like there's a few there's like
two different moments there's the moment
that's like oh [__] I just signed a
record deal my life is officially
changed because that was one year after
where you had already taught which is
which would make anybody be like holy
[__] and it was still a grind and it was
still like for years like even when my
debut album was out like it was still
still and you know I never had a hit
song I had hit records I had hit albums
like my albums like sold well you know
you know uh hundreds of thousands of
copies now Millions but hundreds of
thousands like I was when I was 25 so if
I got my record deal in 2011 by 2015 I
was in Chicago playing 5 000 cap rooms
with no hit nothing on the radio the
radio [__] them all yeah nothing on the
radio but the moment my life [__]
changed I'll never forget I was uh it
was at the MTV Music Awards I gave a
speech after the song 1-800 that you
know about mental mental health and
suicide prevention and I gave a speech
and that speech consisted of of powerful
words regarding uh you know every man
woman and child regardless of race
religion color creed and sexual
orientation and the fight for equality
of all man so
that [__] is seeing like
random ass [__] people like Haley
Steinfeld and like other pop stars like
clapping and being like Oh and crying
and [__] I'm like watching it back I was
like oh [__] I felt like when Kanye
snatched the mic out of Taylor Swift's
hands yeah yeah except like I dropped a
mic like it was it was a it was a wild
thing and I overnight
went from
logic that was known in hip-hop to a
household name [__] doing Ellen and
[__] and then ever since then I kept it
up and then I retired I stepped away
why uh I stepped away because I I was
tired of subjecting myself to the
negativity on the internet because I
still was not at a place where I could
accept the fact it was okay that it hurt
and then learned how to deal with that
pain in a proper and mature way where
which is where I am at now
and I feel yet another huge Resurgence
and and shift in my career because I'm
not here
as a rapper I am here as a [__]
comedian as a writer as a musician as a
rapper on all these things and I'm not
here to promote a [__] tour I'm
really not I'm not here to promote an
album I'm here to be like this is me get
used to seeing me because you're gonna
see me [__] everywhere I [__] love
it dude yeah
um look man thank you for being here
this is been a great interview thank you
yeah I love talking to you thanks for
not asking me [__] boy [__] yeah I mean
that's not who I am I know and I really
and but that's also surreal we had real
conversations yeah we did a real moment
I feel like I made a friend thank you
I'm coming to see you live dude I
appreciate it I'd love to come see you
live you know what I'm saying I'll be
back on stage locally in April when my
lungs can handle you know I've always
wanted to do stand-up maybe maybe one
day you'll let me open for you listen I
do a monthly show when I'm healthy I do
a monthly show at The Comedy Store it's
called The Re-Up with Ryan sickler we
get the best comedians it always sells
out probably gonna bum I will absolutely
let you I'm not even joking I'm gonna do
it this outcome I think my thing though
is I'm not gonna like I'm not a punch
link I'm just gonna tell stories that's
it I'm a Storyteller really yeah yeah I
feel like listen I'm hitting the comedy
store up today for April show and you're
gonna if you're in town you're on it
don't do anybody else's stand-up show
before you come and do mine okay bro
I've never even talked to anybody about
this what are we gonna do there it is
don't go do it okay come out and break I
just have like five minutes and that's
it that's it that's all you need or
maybe like 10 minutes yeah you'll feel
it we'll figure it out oh actually I'm
kind of regretting this you got time
okay yeah we'll figure it out um but
before you go I want to ask you this
because I ask everybody their first time
after I told you about inches
that's good it's a Comcast remote I
measured it one time that's it's a it's
fat too like that it's nice yeah it's
not it's not who's Dick Julie you're uh
uh whose remote you lay your dick on I
hope it was yours it was mine it was a
Chromecast remote it was with my wife
one day and I was like oh [__] look at
this what the [__] that's crazy I could
change your channel you know what I want
to ask you this real quick your mother
is obviously it's been a while she's
never met your wife or your son so
you're flying your dad out to meet your
son you do you anticipate that moment
with your mom someday that no I wish
unfortunately she's uh that's on her
though you're saying not you'd be open
to it if she cleaned up let me let me
tell you something I haven't told
anybody
I my mother is no longer an addict she
doesn't smoke cigarettes anymore she
doesn't drink she doesn't any of this
and I like I've had with my father had a
moment where I was like you know what
[__] it I really want to talk to my mom
and I saw myself as a little boy makes
me emotional I saw myself as a little
boy and I thought about me as a little
boy and my mama
and
that's what I wanted I wanted that
little boy to be able to just hug his
mom again
and I asked my brother I said
can you tell Mom I really want to talk
to her and uh can I have her phone
number
and she told my brother he can write me
a [__] letter damn
so I was like no I'm not and that just
shows where you are mentally and there
it is that's the nail in the coffin so
now I'm focusing on oh I don't know my
godmother Mary Jo who's actually in town
right now with my godfather Bernie and I
met Bernie yeah dude yeah you know so
I'm focused on [__] writing her I let
her write those songs write those hit
songs dude maybe I will write her and
I'll let everyone in the world hear it
through music maybe I will do that yeah
Dear Mama
yeah but you're too father mom Dear Mama
why you smoking crack
are you smoking PCP getting [__] in
the butt damn mama
all right 16 year old self what advice
would you give the 16 year old Bobby
um you know people ask me this
I would say
um
I I think I wouldn't give him advice
because I wouldn't even want him to I
would want him to think his life sucks
and is over and be as motivated as he
possibly could so this is how it's
supposed to be it's how it's supposed to
be but you know what I would tell him if
I could I would tell him I love you and
you're a good person and good job and
keep being you that's what I would tell
him because nobody was there to tell me
that that's right you're not on your own
so that would have that would have been
cool great advice but yeah dude thank
you so much man I've really enjoyed this
a lot um thank you and can I just shout
out everyone listening like please yeah
um you know I'm sure some of my fans are
here but you know I know all your fans
are here and I just want to say thank
you all so much if you made it through
this interview for listening and being
here and and [__] with us and I hope
you had a good time and I just hope you
have an amazing day or evening or
[__] whatever man just keep being
great and spread uh spread that
positivity you're gonna get a ton of
Love on this oh thank you a ton of love
I appreciate we have the best [__]
fans
amazing one more time plug whatever
anything yeah whatever gives a [__]
all right dude thank you for doing this
appreciate it appreciate you dude uh as
always Ryan sickler.com Ryan sickler
we'll talk to you all next wait
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]